botschafter borken danke dass sie sich
zeit für uns genommen haben
gleich zu beginn haben sie den gewählten
präsidenten beiden schon angehalten und
ihm gratuliert nein ich habe noch nicht
zum gratulieren angerufen es steht mir
nicht zu das zu tun
ich denke hat die wahl gewonnen das wird
wie wir wissen in frage gestellt aber
ich sehe keine ernsthafte juristische
oder auf beweis beruhende grundlage für
die annahme er sei nicht der designierte
präsident
wann haben sie denn mit präsident trump
zum letzten mal gesprochen
september am 19 september 2009 10 am tag
bevor ich zurückgetreten bin
vor ein paar tagen haben sie gesagt dass
sie nicht erwarten dass kramp einen
würdevollen abgang macht was erwarten
sie denn genau von ihm
ich glaube wir werden mehr von dem
verhalten sehen dass er bislang an den
tag gelegt hat mehr leute aus seiner
eigenen regierung werden gefeuert werden
eine weitere unterlassung mit den beiden
übergangsteam zusammenzuarbeiten weitere
behauptungen bei den wald vom dritter
november arbeits betrugsfälle gegeben
ich glaube so könnte es potenziell bis
120 stellen sie sich denn seinen abgang
aus dem oval office for wird er zum
beispiel vom secret service heraus
eskortiert werden
nein das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen
aber ich glaube dass es durchaus möglich
ist dass er der amtseinführung von
beiden am zwanzigster januar fern
bleiben wird es ist durchaus möglich
dass er vor noch florida fliegt
das gab es eine amerikanischen
geschichte schon einmal aber es ist
lange her dass der aus dem amt
scheidende präsident der amtseinführung
seines nachfolgers nicht beigewohnt hat
aber ich glaube es recht wahrscheinlich
dass er nicht dabei sein wird
borghorst menschen sie haben es gerade
erwähnt rammt verbreitet weiter haltlose
behauptungen von wahlfälschung und hetzt
so seine anhänger knapp 73 millionen
menschen die ihn gewählt haben auf wie
gefährlich ist dieses verhalten
ich denke das ist potenziell sehr
gefährlich ich wünschte mehr führende
republikaner würden ihre stimme erheben
und erklären dass es keine beweise für
einen umfassenden wahlbetrug gibt dass
die behauptungen des präsidenten und
seine anwälte durch nichts begründet
sind und dass nach allen untersuchungen
sie uns zur verfügung stehen beiden die
wahl gewonnen hat
ob das jemandem gefällt oder nicht ich
halte es für wichtig dies klarzustellen
der hat sich manche leute immer noch
nicht sicher sind
sie würden informationen die den
aussagen des präsidenten widersprechen
dann besser verarbeiten können wenn er
das jedoch widerspruchsfrei sagen darf
wird es später für die leute schwieriger
sein zu überlegen was wirklich die
tatsachen sind
manche leute haben erklärt dass an
trumps behauptungen nichts dran ist
ich gehe davon aus dass noch mehr dies
tun werden ich wünschte sie würden das
früher als später tun
lassen sie uns über die republikaner
sprechen
sie haben gesagt dass dies ein
charaktertest für die republikaner ist
das ist wichtig ist dass führungsfiguren
in der partei sich jetzt fremd
entgegenstellen und offen sagen dass
beiden der rechtmäßige gewinner dieser
wahl ist ehrlich gestanden ist eher das
gegenteil der fall
wir haben gesehen dass bekannte
republikaner wie lindsay graham und ted
cruz dem präsidenten sogar ermutigt
haben seinen weg der klagen und
falschbehauptungen weiter zu verfolgen
fehlt es den republikanern an charakter
manche leute erheben in der tat ihre
stimme und ich glaube noch mehr möchten
ist ich wünschte sie würden es eher
früher als später tun denn es ist
wichtig ein narrativ zu haben das den
präsidenten trump und seinen anwälten
widerspricht solange die menschen nach
dem gegenüber aufgeschlossen sind
was die wahren tatsachen sind wenn wir
einfach schweigen wird es später viel
schwieriger sein die leute von der
wahrheit zu überzeugen sie sagen besser
früher als später aber die republikaner
hatten inzwischen doch etwas zeit und
dennoch schweigt die mehrheit warum
wovor haben sie denn angst versucht
leute einzuschüchtern und in gewissem
maß ist ihm das gelungen
das ist eine der verzerrungen die er das
politische leben in amerika eingebracht
hat in der politik sollte es so
philosophie und ideen gehend nicht um
die persönlichkeit eines einzelnen
mannes oder einer einzelnen frau die die
diskussion beherrschen
das ist ein bestandteil der
weitreichende debatte die die
republikanische partei führen muss nach
dem jump aus dem amt geschieden ist
wir müssen sicherstellen dass nicht die
selbe art von personen oder sogar
dieselbe person die partei 2024 anführen
wird
pony pony vor
glauben sie dass trump uns in
irgendeiner form erhalten bleibt
vielleicht mit einem eigenen
fernsehkanal oder für wie realistisch
halten sie gerüchte dass er noch einmal
zur wahl antritt
das wissen wir nicht und das stört mich
nicht dass ich ihre frage nicht richtig
beantworten kann
denn trump weiß es selbst nicht dafür
müsste er viel weiter voraus denken als
er ist normalerweise tut
ich glaube er wird versuchen in der
republikanischen partei präsent zu sein
ich habe vor dabei zu helfen dass diese
präsenz auf ein minimum begrenzt wird
aber ich glaube er könnte die idee
verbreiten 2024 anzutreten und damit
anderen kampagnen zu schaden die über
eine kandidatur als eine loyalsten
anhänger nachdenken
ich glaube das wird zur unordnung in der
partei führen und das ist nicht gut aber
das ist typisch
was glauben sie was seine intention
dahinter ist hatte eine strategie warum
verbreitet er noch immer diese falsch
nachrichten
ich bin mir nicht sicher ob er sie für
unterhalten hält denn dann behauptet
dass jemand eine liga erzählt impliziert
dass dass er die wahrheit kennt und
vorsätzlich etwas anderes sagt ich
glaube dass schaaf mit vielen fällen den
unterschied zwischen wahrheit und
unwahrheit nicht kennt ich glaube er
sagt dinge von denen er möchte dass sie
wahr sind und sie hofft dass er andere
überreden kann dass sie weisen das was
er sagt war es da nicht beschäftigt ihn
einfach nicht
damit will ich nicht sagen ich würde das
nicht für gefährlich halten
ich glaube nicht dass seine reaktion auf
wahrheit und unwahrheit denen der
meisten menschen entsprachen er will
eine welt erschaffen und andere leute
darin einwickeln hat er neben twitter
dann noch andere verrückte obsessionen
er redet gerne ich halte es für völlig
möglich dass er sich wege sucht dies
weiterhin zu tun
ich halte es für bemerkenswert dass er
eine knapp mehr als zwei wochen sagt der
weise gut wie keinen öffentlichen
auftritt hatte
das zeigt wie schwer ihn das getroffen
hat wenn er raus gehen möchte und das
hatte ein bis zwei mal seit der wahl
getan könnten die seine berater wohl
nicht zurückhalten
aber das hat er nicht getan das
verdeutlicht die folgen der niederlage
was er am meisten auf der welt hasst
sind verlierer und jetzt ist er selbst
ein großer verlierer
sie sagen es er hatte zuletzt keine
großen öffentlichen auftritte und blieb
vor allem drinnen ist es denn richtig
dass er abends gerne viel fernsieht im
bett und mitbürger ich weiß nicht was in
den wohnräumen im weißen haus macht aber
tagsüber im oval office gibt es keinen
fernseher
aber er hat viel zeit und ein kleines
zimmer am ende des flurs verbracht und
ferngesehen
ich bin mir sicher dass irgendjemand
berechnet hat wie viel zeit damit
verbracht hat fernzusehen
ich weiß nicht wie viel zeit das ist
aber es ist deutlich mehr dazu
sein sollen und es ist gewiss mehr als
bei jedem anderen präsidenten in der
geschichte der usa wir kennen viele nur
aus dem fernsehen
können sie uns denn aus dem wirklichen
leben berichten dass trumps auffälligste
macken sind
naja ich habe ein 500 seitiges buch über
meine zeit mit ihm geschrieben ich
wollte es natürlich so fakten basiert
wie möglich schreiben
es enthält schlussfolgerungen mit
beurteilungen die meine eigenen sind
aber ich habe es nicht aus diesem grund
geschrieben ich habe es geschrieben
damit die leute erfahren wie sich der
präsident benimmt und daraus ihre
eigenen schlussfolgerungen ziehen
das heißt ich wichtig jeder hat eine
eigene meinung aber die tatsache ein
bisschen präsentiert werden antennen
botschafter dorthin
sie haben fünf französischen smit erlebt
diese phasen der machtübergabe sind
immer eine sehr sensible zeit für die
nationale sicherheit
diese transition ist besonders speziell
fremd weigert sich noch immer ein
geschmeidigen machtwechsel zu
ermöglichen
wie sehr sollten sich amerikaner aktuell
sorgen um ihre nationale sicherheit
machen
ich denke durchaus dass die gefahren für
die vereinigten staaten gestiegen sind
weil kein normaler übergang autorisiert
worden ist ich kann mich sehr lebhaft an
das jahr 2000 erinnern als ergo damals
george bush siegesserie in frage stellt
37 tage lang weil die wahl nicht formal
entschieden das wirkte sich deutlich auf
übergang zur bush aus unseren archiven
kommission spekulierte sogar dass die
hindernisse für busch sein nationales
sicherheitsteam nach dem zwanzigsten
januar einzusetzen dazu beigetragen
haben könnten nicht auf die angriffe vom
elften september vorbereitet gewesen zu
sein
ich denke das lässt sich schwer beweisen
aber es ergibt sinn dass jeder tag der
vergeht ohne dass das beiden teams
zugang zu geheimdienstlichen
informationen erhält nicht dabei hilft
die liste der leute zusammenzustellen
die führende regierungsämter inne haben
werden im verteidigungsministerium im
außenministerium in den geheimdiensten
nationalen sicherheitsrat
es bedeutet dass beiden weniger gut
vorbereitet ist wenn er sein amt antritt
es gibt also keinen magischen tag oder
einen speziellen termin aber es ist
einfach tatsache je länger sich beide
nicht vorbereiten kann umso
wahrscheinlicher ist es dass er nicht
bereit sein wird umso wahrscheinlicher
ist es dass eher unvorbereitet ist und
nicht die besten entscheidungen trifft
sie haben es selbst eben erwähnt es gibt
noch immer experten die sagen dass die
lange wahl von 2000 blinde flecken bei
sicherheitsdiensten kreiert hat die nine
eleven mit ermöglicht haben
was würden sie sagen wie stark ist das
risiko eines möglichen terrorangriff
oder eines anderen eingriffs feindlicher
mächte durch dieses aktuelles haus
angewachsen nutzen übergangsphase im
allgemeinen und das gilt wohl umso mehr
für diesen übergang in dem sie den
mangel an aufmerksamkeit für ihr
vorgehen ausnutzen
diese aufmerksamkeit entsteht wenn leute
mit dem übergang beschäftigt sind und
sich nicht die vorgänge in der
us-regierung anschauen
sie schauen sich die neuen amtsinhaber
anna konzentrieren sich nicht so sehr
auf das ausland wie sie es sollten
beispielsweise erhielten wir gerade
gestern informationen von
internationalen atomenergie organisation
in wien dass der irak uranhexafluorid in
natans eingeführt hat das ist ein
weiterer ernstzunehmender hinweis auf
ihre bemühungen um nukleare waffen
ich vermute dass der iran bevor beiden
ins amt eingeführt ist versuchen wird
seine aktivitäten in den bereich
nukleare und ballistische raketen
auszuweiten
sie werden also weiter gegen das nuclear
abkommen verstossen als bisher
es stärkt auch ihre verhandlungsposition
gegenüber der beiden regierung es wird
sehr schwierig jemanden nur schinken
dazu zu bewegen diese entwicklung
aufmerksamkeit zu schenken und ich
glaube der iran weiß das und andere die
nordkorea china und russland werden
ebenfalls bereiche suchen bei denen sie
vermuten dass amerikas blick abgewendet
ist und so ihre eigenen interessen
vorantreiben
das ist die wahrscheinlichste art und
weise wie sie die unterbrechungen
ausnutzen werden die sich in dieser
übergangsphase ergibt stichwort iran
diese woche gab es berichte dass kramp
seine generäle nach möglichen
militärischen optionen für den iran
fragte sogar darüber nachgedacht haben
soll atomare anlagen zu bombardieren
könnten sie sich vorstellen dass trump
in den letzten tagen seiner amtszeit
noch ein krieg beginnt den krieg erklärt
oder soldaten schickt nein ich glaube
dass wir ein weiteres beispiel für seine
sprunghafte spontane ungefilterte und
schlecht informierte beschlussfassung
ich halte es für ebenso wahrscheinlich
dass sie morgen einen bericht hören dass
er um ein treffen mit ayatollah khomeini
gebeten hat wurde vielleicht erfährt das
gipfeltreffen mit seinem guten freund
kim jong un er sucht einfach nach dingen
die er tun kann um von der bahn
abzulenken
so etwas schadet den vereinigten staaten
zweifellos d'isere wird die zahl der
dinge die in ordnung gebracht werden
müssen nachdem er sein amt aufgibt
ich nehme das nicht ernst worldcom
beiden
trump begrüßt beiden im weißen haus in
dem er kurz vor dessen amtseinführung
noch soldaten aus afghanistan und dem
irak abziehen
wie wird das die aussenpolitik einer
beiden administrationen beeinflussen
es wird sehr bald entscheidungen darüber
erfordern die beiden politik
hinsichtlich des iraks afghanistans und
der weiteren region naher osten aussehen
muss vielleicht schneller als sie diese
entscheidungen ansonsten getroffen
hätten
es hat die isolationistischen
pazifistischen mitglieder sowohl der
republikanischen als auch der
demokratischen partei sehr gefreut doch
diese entscheidungen sind rein
symbolisch sie beruhen nicht auf
militärischen bedingungen würde der
wirklichkeit vor ort
ich glaube die zahlen sind komplett
ich halte das für einen großen fehler
sowohl was afghanistan als auch was den
iran betrifft wie gesagt jetzt muss sich
beiden überlegen was eine politik sein
wird es gibt wahrscheinlich mehr leute
in der demokratischen partei dies
begrüßen würden das us streitkräfte aus
afghanistan und dem irak abziehen als in
der republikanischen partei
das wird ein früher test dafür sein in
welche richtung beiden gehen
aber inwiefern wäre eine regierung
beiden gut für die sicherheit der
westlichen welt hängt beiden beiden
glaubt an das nato bündnis trump hat das
glaube ich nicht getan
ich glaube aber nicht dass das bedeutet
dass es beiden gleichgültig sein wird ob
nato-mitglieder die karge verpflichtung
aus dem jahr 2014 einhalten werden die
verteidigungsausgaben bis 2024 auf zwei
prozent des bruttoinlandsproduktes zu
erhöhen
vergessen sie nicht barack obama hat im
letzten jahr seiner amtszeit die meisten
europäischen nato-mitglieder als
trittbrettfahrer bezeichnet weil sie
nicht einmal ansatzweise die karte
verpflichtungen erfüllten und über kein
entsprechendes programm verfügten trump
hat das mehr an seiner trump abgesagt
aber ich glaube über das gesamte
politische spektrum der usa hinweg ist
diese ansicht weit verbreitet
dafür vier prozent unseres
bruttoinlandsprodukts für die weltweite
verteidigung ausgeben ist es nicht zu
viel von unseren freunden und
verbündeten in der nato verlangt zwei
prozent ihres bruttoinlandsprodukts aus
danke botschafter baldwin für ihre zeit
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren